Relatively,
but it's not required.
That's why people come to it now.
You can't get the truth from mainstream media.
While I was trying to explain to a friend who was talking about doing a podcast,
a deal with a network and I was like,
stop.
You can't decide one thing that you can have where you can,
it can be mainstream and it's free of everything.
Free of any influence,
and you're going to let a bunch of pen,
pencil pushers and button pressers.
They're gonna tell you what you can and can't say which direction you can and
can't go.
You know they're going to try to influence you,
but isn't Google doing that now?
What do you mean with conservatives?
Like shutting down Dennis Prager.
It's like a fucking,
what do you mean?
W W goes flower as well.
It was owned by go about a company.
Right.
Okay.
What I'm talking about a company,
you going into business with them?
Yeah.
You can wear your podcasts.
You're free and independent.
Right.
It's probably the only thing in the world where you can be completely free and
independent and still reach millions of people.
It really is the only thing in the world.
But,
but,
but how,
what is Google doing?
What I'm saying?
Google owns youtube.
Right,
right.
And uh,
people like Dennis Prager religious right guy is well is show gets shut down on
youtube.
Have we managed shutdown?
They shut at the,
he's suing.
He's sewing fucking gold bowl.
I didn't know about this.
Yeah,
I know.
He does those shows with a Corolla Corolla.
So listen to them.
And I lived in La.
He's a conservative religious Jewish guy.
I've listened to him a hundred.
Yes.
They consider it hate speech.
I mean that's,
that's when we get into dangerous territory.
Wait a minute,
I pull up,
uh,
what,
what happened to him?
Cause I'm,
I'm completely ignorant about this.
This is the first time I'm hearing about this.
So this is going to go to the Supreme Court.
Really?
I think so.
They pulled it.
So they took his page down.
They said you can't have a page on youtube anymore.
Yeah.
They say shut the show down.
Do you remember what it was about?
Not specifically,
but I know it was labeled hate.
And if you listen to this guy for 10 minutes,
he's the most congenial,
fair minded,
uh,
you know,
but he's,
he's a,
you know,
a religious guy.
Do you know that shit doesn't fly in?
Do you know Douglas Murray is,
he's actually a,
her who is,
he's a,
he's a a,
an intellectual from England who wrote about,
wrote the book about immigrants in Europe called the strange death,
I think it's called Islam in the strange death of Europe.
And uh,
he's basically talking about how people from these countries that have
immigrated into Europe or changing the culture,
changing the culture and North Africa.
There's all sorts of,
you know,
crimes and things that are happening that didn't exist before and people are
developing these communities of likeminded people that didn't exist before.
No go zones.
And,
and he's saying that this is,
you know,
this is fundamentally dangerous,
but he's saying it from a point,
a perspective of understanding the actual facts involved and talking about the
situation and talking about how these are people that don't respect homosexuals.
They want to throw them off roofs and they have these opinions.
They have these opinions about people that are extremely antiquated,
not aligned with European values in the modern Western world.
Right.
He and Sam Harris had a conversation and that conversation got flagged on
Youtube.
Uh,
it got flack as someone put it up in there.
You know,
you make a,
like a little watch list.
What is it called?
What was it called?
The v the list.
You could,
will you put it on Youtube,
on your channel where you could the playlist.
So he puts it on his playlist and he gets a compute,
uh,
a community guideline strike against him for putting up this conversation
between two intellectuals.
So I have this conversation with this lady at Youtube and I said,
well,
why,
why would you do that?
Why,
why does that get?
She goes,
well,
it's hate speech.
I go,
Have you talked about to intellectuals having a discussion about a real thing
that's happening right now in Europe?
And you're saying hate speech?
If you listen to the podcast,
there's no slurs used.
Just facts.
They're just talking about.
But this is,
this was the way she said it,
cause it's hate speech.
I'm like,
you had,
you said that so easily.
Yes.
You'd never seen this.
A lot of power,
but it's also a lot of irresponsible power or responsible use of power.
But,
but,
but my point is they're cracking down on people who lean.
Right.
Whether it's Twitter,
yes.
100% true.
Yeah.
And uh,
that's a big fucking problem.
A hate speech.
We're going to let Google decide though.
What's the name of the company that owns alphabet?
Uh,
they're going to decide what,
what I,
I brought that up on.
I brought that up on a tough crowd years ago about when you disagree with a
liberal or whatever you're arguing with,
they always go,
oh,
you're a hater.
They would keep saying that.
And that's what it turned into.
If you just disagreed,
you're a hater now.
It's you're a bigot or a racist.
If you didn't agree with Obama's policies,
you are bigot or a racist and,
and that shit works.
That's been working for the left the years.
But now that the social media,
Google controls almost all the information you want,
you and I hear every day.
I mean,
that's why it's so dangerous.
So look up.
Yeah.
Is uh,
uh,
is the first example that comes to mind.
[inaudible] that guy [inaudible] she me,
um,
uh,
yeah,
because he's,
he's,
you know,
a Christian,
no,
whatever.
But he's not he,
yeah,
he's Jewish.
But,
but you can get up it unless,
unless I'm,
what I just read was wrong.
They weren't w from youtube at least they weren't deleted.
They were restricted.
Put it like me and you're like,
okay,
thanks Shanghai.
Show up that uh,
the,
the adult thing,
like you have to have an account that says you're 18 or older or something like
that.
And they were fighting,
having a lawsuit against that,
saying that what they have in their videos or not shouldn't be behind that.
Like that wall,
whatever that is.
They also then,
but this is my point,
you have to go to youtube to get the store,
hold on.
Sorry.
No,
I'm on their website.
I went to a couple different websites to see it,
but they were also,
like yesterday they had ads blacklisted from Spotify,
so they had ads that were I guess initially approved
and now they have been disapproved and they haven't really explained to them
when those triggers as well.
He's so and so,
but his page is still up,
you know,
Corolla,
don't I?
Yeah,
I believe that's come about.
Yeah.
Well,
but the youtube page is still up.
Your shows not up his own.
His show was shut down.
They might've,
they might've taken it down by now.
This is like,
this is kind of from a couple months ago.
Yeah.
They shut them down.
So if you go to the dentist,
Prager youtube channel,
that doesn't exist.
So the idea that they would make that 18 plus because it's conservative.
That's hilarious.
It's up.
This is it.
Right?
Okay.
This is this channel Bro.
Prager U.
Yeah,
that's true.
But he's got a million subscribers,
million 940 shut his shell down.
I only brought it back up.
Is that what you're saying?
Maybe that he could run any lot.
So do you have a video up from an hour ago?
Spotify,
bands,
Prager from advertising,
Google prego lawsuit.
I mean,
that's what it was about.
It's about them being restricted.
I am angry because we're not getting the full story here.
Well,
I mean that it's up right now.
It's,
he's uh,
he's still on him.
Yeah,
no,
I believe you.
So my point being is these big tech,
big tech companies,
uh,
crushing conservative.
Well,
when's the most part?
Yes.
And here's a good way to look at it.
If you're going after a guy like Dennis Prager.
Yeah.
Who again is most congenial guy,
never swears.
Very,
very mild mannered,
very cool and calm.
And whether you agree with them or disagree with them,
it's not the,
the way to go about something like this.
If you disagree with someone who's not to to shut them down.
I was to have a debate.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And that's not happening.
Well,
you know when you saw the Google memo,
you saw what happened with that guy when he provided all this information about
one of the reasons why women don't get into tech and they labeled him as being a
massage.
This a woman hater and defined like,
no,
he's giving you scientific studies that show that women have different
interests.
Is that Lauren Summers you're talking about?
There's been a few since Lawrence Summers was actually the president of Harvard
and he was giving a speech and that's all he said he was.
He brought up the numbers as far as males go into science and math.
He didn't say women are good at it and he got fucking canned from Auburn.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can't have anything that's fascism.
Yeah.
If it disagrees with the orthodoxy,
they'll come down on you.
Even if it's factual like James Demore and you could clearly back it up.
You could look at the actual numbers.
Not only that that James did,
more guy put a page and a half in there on strategies for encouraging women to
get into tech.
I mean,
if he was a real massage tomorrow,
Google.
Google,
yes.
He's the Google memo,
right?
That was what started off the,
it's all these intellectuals came to his side.
They'd go,
look,
why are we doing all this research?
If you guys completely ignore every time it comes up,
right?
Like you're pretending that this research is not valid.
This research is,
it's it's scientific information that shows that certain types of people are
more interested in different things.
We've known that forever.
That's why boy toys and girl toys are different because boys and girls like
different shit.